oh hey people like to lean back we're
not him he likes to lead for it the
closer he gets to the monitor the more
intensity
I think tomahawk means born to like yeah
all right so this is just beautiful just
to let you know we want to give some
yeah just in case you want to lean back
in frustration they got you baby we'll
go off the stage or be responsible when
you're in your chair but dxracer got you
back
all right here I think oh it's Sophie
it is Sophie so we're gonna go into this
matchup tomahawk versus epic I again
this is loser side top eight loser will
be placing seventh place winner will
move on oh and it's this stage two let's
go seven guys except for the stage just
a bit earlier a little strange a baby
just play it straight up in sop was
gonna a lot of mileage and I say that
that is this man's favorite button let
me tell you nice he was able to beat the
option they're obviously used or fur
guard effect setup able to get the grab
oh he jumped right over here caltrops
follow up anything to do with that staff
oh he's gonna get it he's gonna get he
gets that interrupt there and the launch
at the follow yeah tag throw it to the
immediate offensive follow-up yeah I'm
gonna take your to love my own life and
that's how tomahawk spin this around the
entirety of this tournament right any
time he loses like it's gonna be on him
he's never gonna stay there and take it
at low health it's like I'm not trying
to block all your mix ups look I'm
coming and you just have to make a
choice on how you want to respond to all
your great reactions here from chef
Ricardo getting a huge lethal hit nice
life seat here let's see what tomahawks
able to do
look that he's playing a bit more
defense without waiting for a reaction
here from zepa kite oh he got him again
he's been using that bollocks took great
success and right now is epic a tying it
up one rounded piece just out of range
for that throw attempt for some huff but
it's okay nothing doing all smell that
it's okay and they both ended up in
neutral nice to roll out to escape a
great follow down from self nicest I'm
able to get the throw again the follow
up here let's see what he does to these
players oh my gosh look clutch duck able
to get the punish - yes a fronting in
there a little bit too aggressively and
tomahawk just ready for it but not this
time
not gonna get it to lay the throw
attempt already got him flies back to
back with a 6 6 feet and this time doing
a critical edge post launch and that's
gonna close it out except the guy's
gonna roll up two rounds to one because
she's so precious so he's kind of purses
- she's talking to her sword mace it's
crazy it's crazy man all right I hear
you know that's a terrible thing going
don't be like it's the site the step
again gets the follow-up as well see
what happens agenda critical there with
that 6 6 beat oh hey thanks for playing
I like it three routes to one's f kite
with a statement here reason temple
cosplay everywhere I've seen up six six
feet has just fit to go to win playing
for that young man
wherever's in h-town he's in Texas
trying to figure it out yeah repet for
that house of caliber geez man that six
six be landed every time he needed it it
looks like we're gonna go back to stage
change let's see where we're gonna be
playing this out yeah but here's the
thing right winning the first game
doesn't mean anything we've seen that
the past is right first game means
nothing first game if anything is like a
warm-up right it's like okay well
somebody has the win this so I wonder if
anyone's thinking like I'm at the
disadvantage yeah I'm up one I got to be
careful
potential put this time back and taking
advantage of it being hit on big boss on
it it's up car car trying to press pause
instead instead eco hit yo tomahawk is
going in right now one port hate to do
it he might be working on the perfect oh
whoa oh no oh [ __ ]
not like this you go up 95 percent and
you can't finish your food okay oh my
god I'm so starting to hurt me
physically caliper please yeah that that
has to be bugging them I wonder if the
development team looks at those and like
smiles when they'll have it I was
smiling
alright here's a punishment right here
coming in from tomahawk again more the
same very dominant in that final round
to simply lost to a ringer but that
doesn't mean you can't carry this same
game plan of all dental you just be
worthless taken that's okay yeah and as
a Caesar tournament player tomahawk with
the answer back to back you know what's
crazy he should be a two round or two
rounds no such think it should be it oh
nice but gets launched don't fall for
the combo here again Zephyr type like a
surgeon able to get a cut he has him to
the red to had to do it had a pop it
wants to prevent any further damage to
his guard meter yeah but follow you down
I like the back turn attack from
tomahawk but just outside of his range
and so easy punished you know especially
when you're blocking you're not
necessarily looking for anything let
someone just got a whiff the button is
like cool
okay so sick to follow up here again and
again Zep you know continuing here has a
bigger position put some in the red
again this time Tom I'm trying to
prevent that from happening doesn't want
to get broken I like it
yes into the office and can't tom Hogg
he just doesn't lay down leave this
place here we go able to pop his epic
right now gonna put the pressure on oh
he went for the block of all he's gonna
go for whatever he wants to time off
does not allow you to control the tempo
but the six coming to stop and I think
everybody at home knows this move and
that is gonna be itself a guy actually
able to break the streak yeah we did go
to the final match he made it a
defective and that favorite yeah just
bad positioning you know he only had one
way to roll it in that position
sixty feet getting the job done there's
the fish pump itself is gonna live too